- Okay, newbies.
You're up.
Five, six, ready, work!
[dance music]
Arch those backs, kiddies!
JULES: Am I doing this wrong?
I feel like Velma
searching for her glasses.
- Do you know how
we're nowhere near the places
we thought
we'd be in our lives?
We spent the last part
of our official youth
stuck inside, just here,
watering houseplants.
You have too many plants!
JULES: I saw Wes today.
- Jules?
- I didn't see you.
You were hiding behind
a stack of containers
that are made out of
clear plastic.
STELLA: Are we actually seeing
Jules sexually frustrated?
- I feel like
I'm in eighth grade.
- Well, I can tell you
what I did in eighth grade,
and it involved ruining
several electric toothbrushes.
- Very graphic.
SINGER: It's all about me
- [meow]
JULES: My life
is going nowhere.
[echoing] Nowhere, nowhere...
- Hiya, kittens!
- And here we go again.
JULES: Where are they
all going?
- They're all taking flights
to their future,
just like you two have to do.
Good luck figuring out
where ya wanna go, dollface.
Yee-haw!
- Today is the start of
the new chapter of us.
STELLA: I went to
business school
to become an entrepreneur,
and we're putting up a bar
for women.
A bar with rose on tap,
somewhere where you can
yell at the TV
while watching The Bachelor.
- I just heard the words
rose and Bachelor
in the same sentence, so...
yes to whatever that's for.
SINGER: Let me be too much
- I have decided to work hard
and see where it takes me.
- I will mentor you.
Yes, I have perfect skin
and I'm wildly successful,
but what is my legacy?
- That sounded pretty good.
SINGER: It's really simple
STELLA: Who was that?
He was clearly hitting on you.
- I thought my days of being
attracted to straight men
were behind me,
and yet, here we are.
SINGER: Can't they see me
- You texted a guy
without my input?
[echoing] Input...input?
- So what do we think
of Jules' opening here?
How did that make you all feel?
- Bad.
- Ooh, he might not
remember my name, let me just--
- No, no, no, no, no!
- Who thinks sending a gif
just now was a weird move?
SINGER: It's really simple
- I need a drink.
Pop that shit.
[all squealing]
JULES:
That's how friends work.
Even if it's hard,
you trust each other
and you show up.
Remind me again why you
needed us for this?
- If I had one, what kind
do you think I'd have?
- Circumcised?
- Is it like shoes?
Do you need to walk around
the store a little,
make sure it's comfortable?
- Curve or no curve?
- These are the questions.
SINGER: It's really simple
I'm feeling good